a las vegas man's desperate plea to help
his wife and child evacuate afghanistan
thank you for joining us tonight at five
o'clock i'm sasha loftis though
thousands were able to leave with the
help of u.s troops the sad reality is
many others were left behind in the
hands of the taliban eight news nine
reporter victoria saha spoke to this man
exclusively she joins us from the
newsroom with more tonight victoria
imagine feeling absolutely helpless from
across the world wondering if your
family is dead or alive when you can't
get a hold of them in kabul this is the
daily fear this man is going through
knowing his family's fate now relies on
the taliban
in fear that the taliban may come across
this story this terrified husband just
wants to go by the name muhammad we are
hiding his face and altering his voice
so he isn't recognized there was just
like horrifying
just the stuff that go through your head
what could possibly
happen muhammad is spending many
sleepless nights making sure his
nine-month-old baby and wife are alive
sometimes he goes days without hearing
from them my stomach is like turning and
my stuff is going through my head and i
was like how come she's not responding
to my email
to my text he says when the u.s troops
were helping afghani families evacuate
his wife and baby were waiting in line
in front of the airport with hundreds of
other families desperate to flee before
the taliban took the reins of their
homeland
this is a picture his wife shared giving
you a glimpse of the conditions
basically it was three days and three
nights in the car
with no food
no water
no bathroom
with my nine-month
baby with her that was just one of her
six attempts muhammad says they had all
the necessary paperwork but was denied
when she got to the gate accused of
having fake documents by the taliban she
assumed that
the u.s gonna come through the gate and
get him out of the car and take him
inside
and that that didn't happen either
then she tried again this time she
almost lost her life they hold the gun
on her chest is you don't sit in your
car right now i'm gonna shoot you
and i don't care about you baby or you
muhammad has never met his baby and is
wondering if he will ever get the chance
to why is this happening to me you know
but i just prayed that everything goes
right
here have been in contact with our local
leaders senator jackie rosen's office is
aware of this situation they can't
comment on specific cases but her office
says in a statement in part quote
senator rosen will continue to provide
support and work with nevadans and the
state department on humanitarian efforts
in afghanistan and to assist americans
and afghan allies seeking to depart
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now